movie literally opens with five seconds
of silent black screen before launching
into logos also here's a movie
tangentially related to Cloverfield so
here's another adaptation of misery room
lost and possibly the lovely bones
everything except Cloverfield really
I literally thought there was something
wrong with my hearing for the first
minute of watching this phone says it
626 but her stereo is telling me it's
1216 which seems like a more reasonable
time based on the way it looks outside
but I don't know who to believe anymore
movies opening jump-scare would make a
pretty good dump text and drive PSA but
it's still a jump-scare Howard doesn't
bandit her head at all which is bad for
Michelle but it's worse for Michelle's
pillow why did how her chained her to
the wall but leave her with enough stuff
to MacGyver her way to her belongings on
the other side of the room is it because
the movie wanted to see how long it can
go without dialogue between two
characters selfie stick
not a single app really what are you
gonna do to me I'm going to keep you
alive my boyfriend was expecting me Oh
said the cops looking sorry but no one
is looking for you judging by what we
learned later this guy's just being
mysterious to drag out the movie instead
of just telling her the truth or even
trying to ease her into the truth
instead he allows her to think she's
going to be a sex slave or a solve it to
her both for really no good reason then
turns around the next time he visits and
tells her the truth after she tries to
kill him I said how they really make
crutches super narrow and pointy inside
the rubber foot thereby making it harder
for the rubber foot to stay on I'm
sitting this until a crutch factory
worker comes in here and explains why
they file down the wooden feet into
knives
she's whittling this thing like it
wasn't already pointy enough to pierce a
John Goodman sized person's belly which
it totally was
it's that entire previous sin I wrote
exaggerating it as a knife not to
mention you could swing it like a club
or sword and do great damage to the face
and skull but whatever wood chips
whittling excitement yep she did all
that crook twiddling before even
checking herself for vents and other
escape routes convenient ass matches
here since there are only two left but
we haven't seen her light a cigarette or
anything that would suggest she always
has matches in her purse the only
problem with setting a fire in your cell
to set off the smoke alarm and get him
to come to open the cell is you've got
to live through the smoke inhalation
long enough that and the fact that
you're banking on the fact that a crazy
conspiracy theorist kidnapping dude even
has smoke detectors that look for you
well given us how I saved your life I
think that's acceptable maybe if you
explain this to her a few hours ago we
could have avoided her making a shiv out
of a crotch and almost burning up your
bunker underneath my farmhouse 40 miles
outside Lake Charles the water table in
much of southern Louisiana is too high
for anyone to feasibly build an
underground bunker it would be awfully
soggy down there the Martians finally
figured out a way to get here movie
makes his rambling seem like crazy but
he
ultimately right it's aliens and also
this movie is a lot more conspiracy
theory than I expected
Howard decided that two boxes of fruit
by the foot was necessary supplies for
his underground bunker he may think it's
actual fruit and buying it by the foot
seems like a good deal the guy that
looks like Howard should know what fruit
by the foot is oh hi there Emmet is a
super-loud dreamer or his snore sound
like metal things hitting each other
because I can't find anything within
these two shots that made that sound
let's go bathroom time oh yeah a
bathroom has she not peed in the what 24
hours or more that she's been here or do
we just not want to see that mattress
whose me Meghan's not with us I mean
Howard answers a different question than
the one Michelle actually asked what
happened to them they weren't as lucky
as you you could say that about any pig
really plus how often you get hired to
help build a doomsday bunker in rural
Louisiana
I'm betting more often than we think
Michelle's leg is healed in a matter of
days I bet her regenerative powers are
going to come in handy later how do you
know that Howard was so sloppy earlier
in the film I'm amazed they didn't hear
him coming this time also this is like
the third time john goodman has barged
in on her conversations she might want
to try talking a little lower michelle
anticipates that when howard flips his
lid he'll stand close enough to her she
can expertly take his keys even though
he's looking right at her during the
majority of sandra i know what a traitor
looks like howard doesn't help his cause
by acting criminally insane in fact he
only makes Michelle and the audience
doubt his apocalypse tour and it works
panic character struggles to use Kies
cliche I know Howard is slow but Jesus
it seems like these stairs are a Down
escalator that turned on at the start of
the scene convenient crazy lady showing
up to give Howard's claims validity is
convenient yeah you okay I don't need to
look at for 400 Alex he said Megan
wanted to be an artist but it looks more
to me like she wanted to be a fashion
designer you asked earlier about regrets
yeah I've got some of those welcome to
the club both Michelle and Emmett are
speaking softly to each other facing an
opposite direction
separated by a cinderblock wall and
neither one of them has asked the other
to repeat themselves because they have
trouble here
I hope this jukebox also has I've got
friends in low places so they can keep
playing songs that are oddly applicable
to their current situation movie teases
a movie like cannibal Airlines only for
it to be fake and I can't watch it the
game of life we're missing pieces here
well if it were my house growing up that
just means my older brother stole a few
early so he could guarantee he'd be the
one to put in the last piece and the
placement of the Eiffel Tower on her oh
I can't help it you're the only one
small enough to reach it each what the
filtration system this guy is the king
of over preparedness for disasters man
did not know this girl or anyone other
than him would be down here when he
built this shelter but still made the
air filtration system accessible to only
people 1/5 his size let's talk about
your arm for a second my as Michelle
basically healed from her crash and
Howard's gash on his head is now barely
a scratch but Emmet's arm is still in
the sling no seriously there's a hole
air filtration system room up here that
he built that only a slender girl or
small child could ever hope to get to
and an escape hatch he could never hope
to use this movie is getting bonkers
there are only so many places in the
house where Howard can go how do they
have time enough to go into his room and
discuss this without him hearing them or
not hearing them for long enough to be
suspicious or simply walking in on them
she went missing two years back thank
god this poor bastard stayed in that
homebody 40-mile radius his whole life
so he could provide much-needed
exposition John Goodman porking you
watch the sixteen Candles pretty pink
same difference she tracked anything
back in with her it'd be pretty
concentrated for being so suspicious of
everything Howard seems pretty easy to
manipulate here's why this movie both
works and doesn't work it's five
different movies in one that keeps you
guessing so you were rewarded by
surprises the first time through but
later you realize how the fuck am I
supposed to guess when you're gonna just
hop John or us willy-nilly
I mean it's Criminal Minds meets
conspiracy theory meets a bit of oceans
plus a dash of saw and kiss the girls
maybe thank god this guy had this book
with this page of this information vital
to their escape plan because they've
done a lot of other escape plan prior to
this that would have been wasted yes
this dude is a super prepper nutjob but
make your own gas mask articles come on
he's got a dozen gas masks locked up
somewhere in the shelter and you know it
he's not keeping this piece of paper
around also Emmett and Michelle don't
think to look if Howard has a hazmat
suit before they go through the trouble
to make their own tent tower - such a
doomsday planner one might assume that
he has I had Matt suit in his bunker
somewhere and if he did
they could probably both fit into it
that's racist what exactly is Howard
doing throughout all this escape plan
prep bull
it's like the movie wants me to think he
disappeared for ten minutes worth of
montage wait a minute I recognize this
he's making a bong
I'm Michelle is a I get they were trying
to establish that Howard doesn't see
Michelle as an adult but am I really
supposed to believe that he can't think
of the word woman I guess so
even after the free count clue
description a moment ago and this I ship
penis they still think he's clueless
about their big plan
bride cometh before the oh what do I
care this is either movie borrows a
scare tension element from Breaking Bad
but I ain't even mad because Breaking
Bad tell me what you two are doing with
this not only have we not seen Howard
watching a wall of security monitors we
haven't seen these two here even so much
as look for cameras even though Howard
constantly knows what they're up to and
we never will crying over spilled Emmet
super discount iron man suit also let's
keep null but if the air outside really
is toxic how much good can a shower
curtain an empty soda bottle and a few
rolls of duct tape really do I'm
legitimately asking because I don't know
after I saved you he kept you safe this
is how you repay me Howard was able to
quickly get out of that room even though
Michelle locked the door and threw some
barrels down in front of said door as
this whole movie just been a joker
origin story just like in the lost world
Jurassic Park gymnastics once again save
the day goddamn this guy is the
post-apocalyptic non robot t1000 also
wasn't Howard face down in the acid
earlier why isn't his entire face burned
off are you maybe he's not the Joker but
the acid gave him some superpowers
because he sure is moving a lot quicker
than he used to movie rips off the oh my
god I've got a duct tape my soup
immediately or I'm gonna die scene from
the Martian the Sun set during the three
minutes michelle has been outside the
bunker because the air might not be
toxic but the days are faster
come on they done crystal skull together
[Music]
yes I also saw signs the shower curtain
duct-tape Cola bottle hazmat suit
shouldn't protect my CL from
extraterrestrial gas but it does
Michelle almost passes out but is
revived by finding a lighter note to
self if I'm ever about to be eaten by a
flying Sarlacc alien monster it can be
easily defeated by a makeshift Molotov
cocktail holy
Michelle surprise this conspiracy
theorists tower didn't have a giant
antenna going down to his bunker that
would pick up these frequencies it's
real nice of the radio lady to tell
Michelle about the two cities that she
can go to right if she arrives at the
crossroads for those two exact cities
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
whether the girls get together have a
few laughs
my can dance for a couch I understand no
touchy no touchy
so Janie how's school
is there air you know